[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages coming up we'll see
what's making the headlines with
columnist cara malone
and the editor at courier david clegg
welcome to both of you
to the front pages then let's start with
the metro
germany demands penalties they say
leading on the travel list
suggesting angela merkel wants
quarantine across
europe for british travelers a call
which has found international support
reports the times eu threat to thwart
holidays their headline
eu the guardian rather says there is a
cabinet rift
over plans to grant more travel freedoms
to those who have received both doses of
a coronavirus vaccine
foreign holidays confusion deepens the
telegraph reports that ministers are
accused of
making summer travel more complex
but the daily mail is upbeat declaring
that summer getaways have been
saved football supporters returning
from london after scotland's euro clash
with england
are being blamed for a spike in
coronavirus cases that's according to
david's paper the courier financial
times
leading on the bank of england
attempting to calm fears over inflation
saying they are holding interest rates
and the star reports on the diplomatic
standoff involving the royal navy and
russia
near crimea yesterday in a way that only
the star can
so caroline and david kleger here
welcome to both of you um
the big announcement uh about travel
obviously we await more news next month
and david let's kick off with you then
because the daily mail is very positive
about it holiday islands here we come
they say
yes that's one of the interesting things
of how the papers are are covering it
it's fair to say quite a number of the
papers have been putting as much
pressure as possible on the government
to open up the travel
industry to get flights going back into
europe to get the
industry moving again and the mail in
particular
in tomorrow's edition is taking a very
positive view of this announcement today
they
they're saying we're on our way to a
summer sunshine holiday
uh my personal view on this really is i
don't really
understand why there has been so much
pressure for this i understand if you're
an airline executive if you
if you rely on the the tourism industry
that you're going to be very very keen
to get this up and running but given
we've still
seen this kind of uh certainly a large
spike in cases in scotland uh still
concerned about exactly where we're
going this slight more hesitancy about
opening up in other ways
i personally don't think that a a
holiday abroad is
is a priority for this summer and maybe
the staycation solution
is the way forward the daily mail takes
a different view yet has been pushing
hard for uh for the foreign holidays to
resume
and they seem to be saying that they're
getting their way
that was red ragged carol carol
this isn't just about holidays abroad is
it this is about
opening up an entire industry again this
is it the hospitality industry
sorry we haven't got a great line to you
go on persist we'll try and
otherwise we'll i'm not to blame carol
you've sabotaged it
go on carol have another go are we here
or not
okay so i'm saying it's not just about
having a holiday it's about
reopening the travel industry it's about
re-opening the hospitality industry
generally it's not just about having two
weeks in spain or two weeks in new york
it's
not about that it's about it's we need
it
to sit in this country again and this
shows that he absolutely is
and david talks about increased
infections yes we have like those
16 000 new infections um
or whatever it is in modern technology
terms we will we'll we'll get you back
in a moment
but the point carol was trying to make
there obviously david is that if you if
you have high cases but you don't have
the hospitalizations
putting pressure on the nhs and you
don't have the awful number of deaths
that we saw in
in in lockdown one and lock down two
then why don't you just crack on i mean
that's that's part of the issue here
isn't it so what would you reckon to
that argument
so i think if the government thought it
was entirely safe they wouldn't be doing
this caveat
uh second green list which is a
watchlist now as well i think what
people
including in fact the industry that
carol's talking about what they need
more than anything
is certainty and security about what is
going on
so if we think it's safe and we don't
think it's going to have a
negative impact on people's health or a
god forbid
and increase the fatality rate from
covered then we should go ahead and
there's
there's no doubt about that if however
we think that there is a risk here if we
do think that it's dangerous if we do
think we have to be careful
about it what i think the industry need
is support and clarity about what
exactly is going to be possible
and what exactly it is going to be so
the government have announced today
this this idea of a green watch list
which is an attempt to
not see a repeat of the chaos that we
saw with the portugal situation where
people were given very little notice
that
this was changing there's 13 of the 14
countries that have been put on the
green list
that are are on a green watch list which
is a warning that they could be changed
at a very very short notice so what that
says to me is that this idea that this
is all safe and they don't think it's
going to be a problem
isn't isn't quite correct because if it
was correct what would be the need for
that
what we find is that it's certainly true
that the thanks to the brilliant rule
out of the uk's
vaccination program that link between
getting covered
and uh ending up in hospital has been
has been broken especially if you're
double jabbed
but we're not we're not there yet and i
do think that
rather than rush into this there should
be this uh
there should be a patient approach taken
and if that means having to delay
the the summer holidays having to not
get this industry reopened as quickly as
we might have want let's just support
that industry in other ways
and make sure that they get certainty
and clarity about what's going to happen
in the in the weeks and months ahead
yes 13 out of 14 of the newly named
green countries as you said going on a
green watch list malta was the
nation that did not israel also added to
greenwatch which has really irritated
the daily telegraph
suggesting that holiday confusion has
deepened uh holidaymakers have been told
their plans could be upset at the last
minute
the other thing that could upset plans
is the lead for the metro which is
first of all uh germany's uh merkel
and now france's macro suggesting that
there should be an eu-wide approach to
british holidaymakers who both have to
quarantine in those nations
along with belgium as well um and italy
i think too
um so you know we we may well be
rejected because of the delta variant by
the european countries we want to go to
yeah so i think there's two interesting
things there the telegraph which has
also been pushing for the industries
the industry to be opened up for the
flights to get running for the holidays
to get up and going
they are they are much more sniffy about
the government's announcement today they
are
they're much more saying that this is
going to cause more confusion they don't
think it's far enough the
they're quoting industry voices
uh complaining about the way this is
being executed so the daily mail's
optimism
about it is not shared by everyone there
then the metro i think makes what could
ultimately be the most important point
here because
uh angela merkel the german chancellor
she's been raising concerns about the uk
she's
asking for her partners in the eu to
band together and have a wider approach
across the
eu about this 14 day
period that you have to self-isolate uh
quarantine uh if you if you arrive in
germany from the uk so we could actually
see the
uh the uk government saying let's get
the industry up and running let's go but
actually the country said well no that's
not going to
that's not going to work quite quite so
well so i think this is obviously a very
complicated situation as with all these
decisions about the the reopening
of coronavirus they're very very
complicated they're finely tuned
balanced decisions uh but also we also
have the situation here where it's more
than just one government
in any kind of tourist transaction it's
going to involve both countries agreeing
about how this operates
so so i do think there's there's you
know difficulty ahead here
yes and the and the other bit that
people were waiting for carol
is can the double jabs jabbed go to
ambulance countries and come back and
not quarantine
a very long statement from the
department for transport this evening
our intention is that later in the
summer arrivals who are fully vaccinated
will not have to quarantine when
traveling from ambulance countries
we expect this to occur in phases
starting with uk residents
they will still be required to take a
pre-departure test
and a test on day two and any positive
results will then be
sequenced at the same time we do intend
to remove the guidance
that people should not travel to
ambulance countries
so that will be interesting all waiting
to find out what you do with the under
18s and
and the non-vaccinated so that's a
decision still to come
parked until next month um what what's
your feeling about the double jabbed
having some liberty um
well yes but it depends when that
liberty is going to come it could come
too late for the travel industry the
travel ministry can't afford to lose
another summer in this country um and
you know and i know mrs merkel is
actually saying that uh there should be
a 14-day warranty
and macron has joined in and she's
trying to persuade the other eu
countries
i don't think she's going to be able to
do that actually because
the british pound is it's very important
to those countries you know places like
spain and portugal
i mean italy now has a five-day equality
but we're still very important to them
and i'm not entirely sure these
countries will listen to mrs merkel and
macron who i'm sure are
um i'm sure there's more involved in
this and just the safety of the people
of their country
um but i but i i don't think they're
going to be able to hold
the brits from going to europe this
summer so yes
and it would be fantastic if those of us
who are double jabbed are going to be
able to get away
um but it's not going to be any good if
they're going to wait until september to
do it
okay carol i just want to bring in your
paper the career we saw all those
thousands of scottish fans uh come down
with no home to go to a pot from
perhaps leicester square in a bar um
what's happened as they return because
we've had some high figures across the
uk which is
partly surge testing in scotland isn't
it yeah the last two days in scotland
have been the two highest days on record
so it was 3 000 or just under 3 000 new
cases today and where i am in dundee
there was a health board meeting today
where one of the board members put this
down explicitly
to football fans returning from london
there was one coach
uh going back to perfsher where there
was a covet outbreak another one
uh in angus here uh and you know
it is it is it isn't funny but it does
seem that all the scotland fans maybe
got from that game was uh was an
outbreak of covet in some cases
it may not come from england but david
it may not come from england it might
have just come from them mingling
yeah no i think i i think there's
certainly not a suggestion that it's
just came from england i think it is
very much the
the social interaction the lack of
social distancing that was go that was
going on
here and and what the i think the proof
really is that the
for the first time ever really the new
cases are overwhelmingly male
uh there's not really been much
disparity between men and women up to
now but the the new cases that we've
been seeing in the last few days there's
been a preponderance of them have been
men
fascinating that's that's very
interesting isn't it certainly uh
keeping an eye on that in scotland
plenty more still to come though in the
next part of our program this on the
front page of the
financial times george osborne has been
appointed to lead the british museum
what do you make of that
back in a moment
[Music]
[Music]
it's it's my own anecdotes um stories
that didn't make it into my other books
but also the stories of other explorers
leaders in different fields
in business in sports in industry
everyone from astronauts to the dalai
lama so
it's kind of all the wisdom that i've
picked up along the way from some of the
most remote and fascinating communities
in the world
i met the dalai lama in india on my
walking the himalayas
expedition and so he imparted some of
his sort of guidance
um but for me it was actually just the
normal people that i met along the way
from
shepherds to pirates to uh to cannibal
monks i mean i've met i've met a lot
really and so it's people like that
who've told me different ways of life
different ways of living and what i've
tried to do is compile all of that into
the themes and lessons
um that hopefully people can take away
and use in daily life so it's not just
for people who perhaps want to be a
professional explorer
um this book really is for for anyone
from career changers to um
to people that just want to take a
different perspective on life
there's a lot of stories in there from
my time in the army um all the way
through to from my sort of when i
started my own basic training
to the the lessons in leadership and
teamwork that i learnt on the ground
in places like afghanistan so
really i focus on you know how to build
a team how do you get the best out of
people how do you motivate people
leading by example that's a really key
facet to you know buy into any leader
you've got to lead
from the front you've got to show people
that you're willing to do
the most difficult dangerous jobs
yourself in order to inspire
and motivate your team so it's all those
sorts of lessons
and i think what the readers will get
out of it hopefully
is is that sense of both practical
applicability
um and just hopefully most motivating
people you know we've all been stuck
inside for a very long time now
i think we're all ready to uh get out
and travel and uh and explore the world
again so it's about like
adopting the explorers mindset and
uh you know humans have you know i've
got this innate curiosity it's been with
us since we've
we've evolved and um sadly you know
we've kind of been stuck inside we've
not been able to release that
so i'm hopefully encouraging everybody
to to tap back into their inner explorer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
done
[Applause]
hello or like we say in my language is
lay i am tonitiv the founder and the ceo
of renewables in africa this picture
changed my whole career
and my whole life our mission is simple
is to bring back power
to is to turn africa
dark continent that i saw in 2008 into a
brighter and prosperous
one by 2014.
[Applause]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me our columnist
carol malone and
editor of the courier in dundee david
clegg welcome back to both of you
um so uh we saw that bryce johnson
promised to do something about obesity
after his brush with covid last year
and junk food tv ads is one element of
doing this carol
you know it's this is just a load of
nonsense the government
keep on coming up with these initiatives
uh none of which have the vaguest effect
on obesity stats
you know we you know there was there was
there was the sugar tax
it hasn't changed obesity at all in fact
since the sugar tax
obesity's got higher in other countries
where they've tried the sugar attacks
places like mexico
it hasn't worked either and they find
that you know by putting this tax on
reduces
kids calories by something like two one
or two calories a day it's nonsense
this isn't going to make any difference
you know the government keeps on
thinking if
it bans things it's gonna actually
tackle obesity
it isn't the only way to tackle obesity
in this country is to have a
you've got to have a change in in
culture it's got to be a cultural change
in the same way
that smoking became naf we have to make
being obese now you know people people
saw those photographs on the side of
fact packets
we the way we talked about smoking where
we acted about it
it became a terrible thing to do but
possibly
advertising ban part of the reason that
attitudes to smoking change though carol
no i don't think it was i think it was
the uh it was the amount of illness it
changed you know we keep on saying to
people
you know we we live in a country where
it's you cannot tell someone they're
overweight
in case it upsets them gps are not
allowed to say to
children or adults you are overweight
you must do something about it
which is a crazy situation to be in we
call it fat shaming it's wrong
you have to tell people what they're
doing is they're killing themselves you
know
we have a situation now where kids are
going to be dying before their parents
because they're obese david do you want
to do you want to crack home without or
do you want to go to the next one
i can i can crack on i i i mean i i
think we've seen some of these
advertising bans actually working and
changing attitudes part of the way
part of the way that you change
attitudes is to
um the the public perception of it is
shaped by how society feels about it and
just even the message of saying this is
not something that we should be
advertising to children because it's bad
for them i think actually has a positive
a positive message there that's slightly
different to banning the product in
itself
which we've we've also seen in other
instances as well so i i think
actually that we might find because some
of these uh proposals have been watered
down
that some uh in in the health industry
will have wanted the government to go
further
so i certainly think this seems like a
pretty modest proposal which is a good
idea because of the cost both in health
and to the public purse of trading
obesity
is worthwhile we're going to have to end
it